so we do a thousands of people a day and
come to us they're obese thousands a day
at least a half a pound of 2 pounds a
day I'll share one example but we have a
thousands and Abel is 25 pounds of they
needed to lose 140 pounds in a hundred
days that kind of stuff this fella here
a pastor from Charlotte North Carolina
I haven't ledbetter he is six one hears
his son who plays basketball and
football you know he weighs about 260
he's six foot five
but he's four 123 pounds Asher we put
him on the program for weight loss is
called a healthy weight love pack right
and you lost 17 pounds in the first week
thirteen eighty which is part of the
program as slim as Papa was not
impossible
well 60 pounds of first 30-day there two
pounds a day went from 400 pounds at
that point 265 pounds in seven months
and here he is 10 months later oh yeah
it's also on Dallas and they have a
pressure diabetes all that's often
forgotten muffin dialysis we go I got
rid of this high pressure and high
Cody's has gone today simple efficiency
of a single memory analysis is there's
nothing wrong with your kid you when you
have dialysis treatment when you have
Kenny go in quickly analysis there's
nothing wrong with your kidney what
happens is you get obstructive disease
you get inflammation obstructive
artery disease your kidneys and the
filters won't work with the kidneys
because
the dirty bloody work on so the kiddies
just going to hibernation camp
so the filtration rate goes down the
campaign goes up because they can't do
anything how there's no dirty legged
minute so about 25 years ago we learned
how to encourage the instructor to
already to allow blood to come through
okay and we got the blood flowing again
and we take people having urinated in
ten years on Dallas to six days a week
for ten years and have been on bounces
ten years before that maybe two weeks to
two months they start urinating again
and another couple months are all the
dialysis even as they've been halved
I've used for thirty years or thirty
days or next I better type one type one
you might be able to reduce the amount
of medication they take by nine percent
ago I wouldn't take a little bit of
insulin for they don't make it or not
enough I have two diabetics they make
ten times more than they really need
there's just no communication for the
insulin to the cells until you give them
that nutrient then suddenly all works
and do it for 36 years and it never
fails it never fails I like having a
combination of combination lock it
always works
I've already talked about athletes we
don't have to go into detail there now
comes the real AC stuff
they awake here folks this is what's
gonna save you and your children your
brothers and sisters your church mates
your neighbours workmates this is good I
can make America type UW's free country
in two months
okay again that's whether having me
speak foundations October this year but
those two disease obesity tonight is for
breaking industrialized nations
financially well there are twenty
cultures that the issue Geographic ranks
as top plane longevity cultures that's
one of my passions is to I want to live
the 200 or more and be biologically like
thirty it's doable but you're gonna have
to give your genes or DNA or RNA and
your tumblers everything they need to
maximize your genetic potential for
longevity and health and fending off
disease and speed and strengthen and
tone this just is like putting the right
type of oil in your Lamborghini every
thousand miles same principle right and
so I want to know what is it with these
top 20 longevity cultures where each one
of them features a cutter article in
National Geographic over the last sixty
years how come the National Geographic
just put them all on one issue of my
question so we put them all book
we found out these type xxi duty
cultures have 40 times 100 we do that
100 over 250 to population we have one
federal per 10,000 have 40 times hundred
we do they're illiterate their thermal
cultures they don't have doctors
insurance governor private they do not
have emergency services they don't have
Hospital their clients they have no
utilities no indoor plumbing
they have no roads no cars no phones no
TVs no radios no computers they don't
have anything you would think of as a
big modern why would you go there for
anything for god sakes and have a drive
sort of any kind nobody has cars and you
know I didn't move around in Burrell
what turns out they had 23 common
threads which you all can do at home
they put all these 23 common threats
based on each culture we did each
culture and then we have a summary and
all cultures most statistic put together
here very simple creative and pick out
what you need to do I'm going to show
you some details in a moment but
basically again one thing they do is low
in calories tribute I heard that every
surgeon that will help you live longer
okay go ahead about to 25% again account
restricted that works because you need a
lot of food you need more nutrition to
deal with it but analyze that food
they're taking less calories don't eat
so much nutrition so your little
deficient won't make a big difference
retain lots of calories here a little
bit sufficient it's going to kill you
that's my chemistry - that works is
because you don't need so much nutrition
none of them get any bad stuff was you
know the drive-through again for people
move around a girl so don't get fried
foods and a big party two drinks on like
my stuff if you get the 90 substitutions
I'll show you how they do that in a
minute they take in ten times the ORAC
points we do which is a measurement of
how many free radicals are neutralized
with the antioxidant food this is May
2013 particle emissions Geographic they
had five different issues there's one
issue magazine one print magazine that
had five different covers everything
that had a negative is exactly the same
everything only covers exactly the same
except for the picture of the kid
one-fifth of the issues had a picture of
brown kit other one-fifth had black tip
another one had where young kid nothing
that white kid other one had a Native
American kid never won races took the
picture that our baby on the cover would
you assume that's what they
so they saw more issues than this one
magazine made 2013 NGOs but everybody
wanted to picture their own baby let's
look at Villiers I've been asking God
for 20 years
magazine other organizations tell
me about billionaires I'm going to know
what sickness is again I want to know
whether every life and what he died from
I came up with a CD called what kills
billionaires and they they got
permission for me to use it as a title
for one of their articles I mean 2004
this came out didn't look up my CD what
killed billionaires and they said the
average lifespan of a billionaire 78 but
again if you live in Ridgeland v78 has
not excited so they got the top purple
trainers they had exercise equipment put
their limos where they drove from home
to work there marks a workout and on
weight work they put gymnasiums and
their offices and their homes but the
doctors told them that the people who
live a long time you know they weren't
physically 12 hours a day seven days a
week and you're living on computers and
so that's why you're heavily probably
chose a time when we're are give me give
me ten our sweat okay okay why the
billionaires are just working out like
crazy well March 2011 they reran
Spadafora magazine and remember in 2004
the recollection was 78 in 2011 their
ads live in with 66 they lost 12 years
those closures of average lifespan at 12
years of time how many I've been working
out there eating meals were a thousand
bucks each I mean organic and prepared
by the best buys to our vegan chef and
all the cons government but now one
person told them to take the 90
essential nutrients so nobody took
bottoms America's just like after the
same principle they all done just like
this fella here each chose poorly if I
start Indian chef exactly as a chef said
smart techie a billionaire about 56 yes
Steve Jobs Giannini well did for him Wow
you did
now the oldest man in America ever
recorded and documented was a guy named
George Francis who died in December of
2008 he lived in the swamps of Louisiana
but you already know where I'm going we
lived in the swamps Louisiana he was
illiterate he lived in a cabin that was
built by his great-great Grandaddy
journey slave days
he died in 112 documented by the US
government and he outlived 19 US
presidents he lives here 19 years
presents the average lifespan who was 75
the doctors who cared for these 19 US
presidents for their flyphone 56 exactly
having charges age and here's his
daughter reading the newspaper him
because he was illiterate when he died a
hunch while I reported asked his
daughter when her daddy didn't even talk
she said he drove all the rules of
healthy meeting who came up the rules
and how many medical doctors who lived
me 56 I love it when reporters interview
little old ladies for one hundred ten
hundred twelve there's one in the
newspaper this morning who did have 100
16th birthday she class does the oldest
living person right now in the world is
documented I think probably United
States I wouldn't say the world
certainly in nine states the oldest
living person and they asked her what
she treated her long - she says it's God
well I believe that there you go for
that but I believe it's more than God
anything is God systems now if you tap
into God's systems you're do better than
if you just believe in God you don't tap
into his systems that makes
and colleague being on the prayer list
and never doing anything
the even frill isn't quite enough you
have to change all the bad stuff right
and do more the good stuff that takes
some responsibility here so I really
appreciate it his daughter's answer
she said he broke all the rules of
healthy eating with a diet heavy pennies
were to used on dairy products eggs and
large sandwiches people ate for poor
Crisco huh
he lived in this camp and had a potbelly
stove and dirt floor in his living by
catching crawdads and can't fish to sell
the occasion restaurants and he lived
being robbed right in the picture here
it's always a third-world situation it's
never a billionaires never the top 60
million dollar-a-year athlete who lives
to be a hundred
it's always the third world culture
person always I'm going to show you why
we know exactly why but when you examine
all of them and you have the green
agriculture so you kind of inspect that
piece you have degree matter now so you
expect that inspect that piece
pathologist I looked at that and I'm a
primary care physician I looked at that
so we know exactly why this is the
scenario that it is honey ever heard
rare earths raise your hand rare earths
ok rare earths have to do in modern
times the computers you know one beat
one little battery the seismic beam is
made out of Everton power whole town is
a really powerful stuff and rare earths
are nine of them that I know of and six
of them and heavily research and
research shows
they actually double Iceman's the
laboratory and let us say take
laboratory rats you get a half of them
Ralston Purina laboratory rat pellets
and they live me six years old making
this another group the study group you
give the same alfalfa pellets from
laboratory rat pellets from rolls from
Tree of Life you grind them up into
powder
he's throwing any one of the rares any
one of them here being nutrient samarium
europium the Italian pasta any one of
those in study but any one of them one
thousandth of one microgram one
thousands of one microgram in that color
it'll tell Elijah Lizzy 12m says six and
so in that book rare-earth ventures
which talks about all these mineral
deficiencies that cause people do beasts
and all these different Z's including
diabetes and mustard history in six red
roses and all these other birth defects
and malukas and on how stuff here errors
are talking about quite heavily in here
and okay and also the book in mortality
Aleutian to pay the Department of Public
Health of Harvard Medical School in 1990
where to do something for America so he
did study county-by-county was looking
for the secret which tally an American
who lived longer and he checked medical
records very County United States sent
team down to look at him and he found
the ones that lived the longest he found
the ones that lived the shortest there's
a 25-year difference he said no there's
got to be some difference in how they
treat patient goals and how GP treatment
patients and ones that lived the longest
he put in purple he found they lived in
Midwest every Midwest
for both females and males okay the
purple live the longest and the ones in
the yellow orange and red line the Old
Confederate States Cook County Chicago
Lake County area west of the Mississippi
River they're almost all red orange and
yellow or an Indian Reservation
these people don't live as long okay one
purple 25 you're different and so what
isn't it they all have the same medical
care even people living under the bridge
get the same medical care it's a
billionaire I mean somebody living under
the bridge if they could stumble into
the emergency room emergency room
doctors give the very best care oh you
pay all right so just because they're
living on the bridge doesn't mean
they're going to get neglected I mean
they get very tested gonna be they're
gonna get treated the best at hopple
care right everything's the same so if
the medical system same why they're 25
year difference would pay the ones in
the Midwest government west the plain
States and the Old Confederate States in
Chicago and Gary and damn Indian
Reservation 25 you're different
significant because of how they eat and
the nutrition in the soil and where they
live
we're beginning to get a picture here
I should show you one does the let's
fish look at cardiovascular disease
don't you notice that that's kind of the
same patterns I just showed you and is
longevity the worst places are in the
burgundy the dark red you know it's in
Alaska there's no heart disease all he
asked was are eating us what will we eat
whale blubber their clutch wall is very
hundred fifty five hundred they don't
even have any predators in Wow
ground zero for the worst possible place
in America for heart disease and obesity
and diabetes and cancer is Jackson
Mississippi where I'm going Monday I
like it about six times a year kind of
sane people
okay as matter they can so what's going
on here well there's little or no
selenium in this fall here Little Italy
and so in these places okay
and as a result a Accord about the heart
disease
cataracts they get a stretch of artery
disease you know all kinds of stuff
they get final mile Joe the baby with
birth defects so then it must miss me
and so on the heart attacks are a big
thing here sudden heart attack
I'm going to show you a quick one here
his gluten intolerance I really need to
move this closer everybody this little
you see he's three months old here being
breastfed by his mama he's born with his
ex well where every square millimeter
his body the little penises but up in
his nostrils and his eyelids as clever
the whites of his eyes or covers eczema
he has asthma just born that way his
mama's 28 years old she had the same
thing asthma eczema when she was born it
got worse worse worse at age 28 it
really bad for her position was caring
for use he told her to get one of these
infant monitors when he wheezed at night
run in there and sprain with an inhaler
Roseanna told me keep his finger nails
clipped put mittens on him and put
cortisone cream on his top theaters for
his neck
well you put on a gluten-free diet here
the 97 even 60 ml 15 buy them as close
as you guys miss me as much of any
assets and to expand for asthma asthma
she had which was getting worse for 28
years
I remember she's breastfeeding him all
the juices are coming through her breast
milk in the same two weeks that she got
rid of her asthma eczema well you see
the husband eggs a little way reason 2
years of age he's on his own
gluten-free diet his own tiny
centenarians
you tell me look at him he doesn't have
a head for eggs anymore keeping left
alone and not given the 90 seconds and
standing looking free diet
guys are going to die by this time
are you getting a picture here yeah this
is in your hand you can't unknow what
you know I can't put the genie in the
bottle now the scary thing is you know
more than most doctors at this point
there's not scary that you know it is
scary that they don't know it they're
seeing hundreds of patients every week
which is very very scary the same thing
works with psoriasis it'd take a little
bit longer for six weeks for psoriasis
to go away there her lupus raise your
hand you know and you've seen anybody
was lupus systemic lupus they have this
rosacea their faces a little butterfly
rash their face a very characteristic
and if you came on a gluten-free diet in
under 90 seconds appropriate for the
body weight Loomis goes away in a couple
ways
no means a simple nutritional deficiency
caused by the lack of ability test okay
okay let's talk a little bit more about
the 90 cents of nutrients and we'll
summarize it up how long do you need
water for like how long any oxygen now
you got what I didn't take long you
learn quick 97 nutrients this is how
difficult do you think some fuel is
clara's doctors fail to figure that out
ninety-seven nutrients to call the same
solutions for multiple reasons are the
two most important you can't figure you
must eat him every day it is food or
supplements or combination usually of
both food and supplements also the busy
Brent Lincoln time to get home Lizzy's
all of us are ultimately fail these 60
middle which are 2009 senators who the
Middle's reported these 16 vitamins
amino acids 3 fatty acids and all these
are required by your genes your DNA to
earning your telomeres to maximize your
genetic potential for longevity and for
health and fending off disease and
strengthen and speeding intelligence and
all the things you think of as being
dealt with by genetics your gene is not
working it on Thomas fashion it requires
all these raw materials to function as
optimal capacity is like that
Lamborghini car
this is a article from the April 16 2012
issue of food and chemistry very
well-respected Carol I read it all the
time
whether the first paper of mass valve in
America published in 1962 and this has
to do with reporting of foods that are
harvested every month from the United
States in county-by-county listed by
Counting and tells you the pollution
load in which I was interested in plus
they began to learn what nutrients when
foods grow in a different place you can
see how they occur in strange patterns
well this particular issue April 16 2012
they looked at the nutritional value of
inclusion load the top 8 baby partners
burgers in the mills from my point of
Erica motors may never find radon right
what they say was first available base
but it may contain less than 30% give me
less than 20% are the recommended levels
of minerals and vitamins remember you
need 60 min or then once you do I defy
you to find a commercially available
baby food in the store go look at
Enfamil Similac and her baby formulas on
the Shelf the grocery stores finding one
that has 16 minerals of ultimately have
13 are left from between 9 and 13 I had
there's nothing about my 8 loss because
I had to assume in federal court to get
slain him in there
okay I want you look that up so what
you're gonna have to do say your babies
ratings what you're having to supplement
them cause it's not in the food now how
did now I'm going to show you something
I think you'll recognize is my things
importantly it's worth three three
minutes this is a Sunday magazine from
The Globe and Mail which is kind of a
USA Today type newspapers the national
newspaper in Canada comes out every day
including the weekend this is a weekend
magazine kind of great magazine to them
and the doctors up they were having
impact char alone I'm sure once you
stand up for his way to everybody she's
been with me for 25 years she's
responsible for 500,000 my patients okay
she deals with them electronically every
day she piece of information feeds em
information right and so Canada they're
having quite an interesting time because
she has 25,000 patients in Canada alone
in Ontario just right there in her and
so the doctors are very getting offended
and so they say why do you want to take
all these vitamins minerals for
nutrients but Disney well just eat well
you're unique
well I defy you to tell me how many
milligrams of calcium you idiot from a 1
inch wedge to that green apple but you
want to do a $2,500 analysis of every
piece of food II find what sentencing
and then make up the supplement I defy
you to tell me how many international
about a man a are beta carotenes in a 1
inch wedge that's made it up and
analysis what about fully Gaston how
many at my program to pull against their
sleeves in money's way to that yeol bell
pepper I know how much is in every one
of these things
I wouldn't take all that stuff but if
you know we have liquids that have 245
nutrients in the liquid never take all
those pills in capsule it right so they
got down to the science Tory can
guarantee Rin guarantee now sure are
even taken enough stuff by body weight
for a 200-pound guy twice a day for how
long now going 25 years what was the
last time you were sick I want to stand
up again please be space key audience
please and April shows you turn how old
you will always look 30 to 50 years
younger now in a week I'm 2076 I am into
a doctor in 68 years
I've never been on medication I've ever
had any surgery my blood pressure runs
90 over 60 my pulse is 36 and char was
witness we had the insurance companies
have sent a nurse practitioner and PA to
my house for their kids to go see
doctors and so they threatened to murder
me by the way on the air on the radio
they thought their on the telephone yeah
and um and so any rate so I had them as
witnesses and actually he has done by
PAS and nurse practitioners for the
insurance company for my life insurance
for my wife for some hams me and they
just said well you got blood thinners
your pulse only 36 you're gonna get
blood clot I gave you a blood clot but I
take in 19 grams nineteen thousand
milligrams of omega-3 is every day do
they apply so much I want to marry
embolism her a heart Rhambo satori-sama
body stroke I take in 19 grams nineteen
thousand milligrams these omega-3s every
day along with all the other 89
essential nutrients right so I'm not
worried
yeah and happen in 68 years right and so
what did what did rich people pharaohs
do 8,000 years ago get their mirrors
they paid grave robbers great sums a
silver and gold to get the mummies who
are supposed to live forever and it
would grind these mummies of any money
dust is their source of Merrill's it's
like bone meal are we call it seven lets
it come from coral reefs coral is just
skeletons of little animals will see
animals is why not a skeleton a human
being today that's how they got their
memories well so if this is farmers and
slaves couldn't afford these things and
so where do they get their nutrients
this a little bit
change the place a little bit here Harry
how do you remember going to your
Grandma and Grandpa's house they're old
enough remember going your mom and dad's
house Ned would so if I remember the
woodstove days okay what did your mom
and dad or your grandma grandpa what do
they do with what actually they couldn't
recycling been the same the earth where
the wood ashes go and the vegetable
garden exactly right what does a
vegetable garden
now what ashes are not anxious what
answer they're really minerals 95 to 90
percent of that powder that we call wood
ash that are really metals that the tree
sucked up out of the ground and the
nature and amount and variety of another
than those ashes will depend on where
the tree grew the nutritional do not
occur uniform black run because heard
they occurred in pain let's talk about
darker black room someplace there's not
some things there's just a modest amount
some places are okay mounted and some
things are like I guarantee you wherever
people live a long time they have a lot
of fun they take these wood ash and they
throw them in the garden and the trees
suck up up you burn the trees and throw
the wood ashes into the garden and guess
what the peas the bees the squash it's
made of the okra bell peppers the state
became the I needed to suck up all these
minerals to eat them that's how we got
our mineral supplements for thousands
and thousands and thousands and
thousands of years let's reply from the
amp noon Monday September 4th 1882 on
Pearl Street New York City it all
changed in a heartbeat it all changed at
3 o'clock in the afternoon Monday
September 4th 1882
on Pearl Street in New York City and a
bluff overlooking the construction of
Brooklyn Bridge an event happened who's
in every newspaper in the world the next
favorite right we had the Telegraph the
story went out across the world and the
next day
everybody's favorite world this fella
here
Thomas Essen had pulled the switch from
the first commercial energy generating
plan within ten years every time in
every city in the industrialized world
converted from what is the universal
fuel electricity I don't care if you
remember anything I've told you so far
why don't you take home this next
paragraph you okay this one we should
take home you kill your home electricity
you feel your home electricity how many
wood ashes are left over your home every
morning and what did you replace your
source of official mineral supplements
with right now here's a little grandma
Ruthie a some years old Jesus urn feels
to make some pains and she sees an ad on
TV for boost and then sure maybe one day
vitamin dr. Frank I saw the stuff about
insurance and what are they shouldn't I
be something that my dad some items
minerals or something else
I want you to use every good German
chemistry Armus noodles
they begin you get the picture here dad
every doctor who said that should be put
in jail for murder
they killed little grandma Ruthie as
sure as he shot her in the head
she was asking she fate you shouldn't I
be taking somebody on our Jersey well
you'll wanted to play Steve Jobs then 56
and beginning to get the picture here
he should've at least a well yeah I
really don't believe in a much but can't
hurt you go ahead and take a supplement
if you want I do some good they never do
they always say don't do the overdose so
what what was the overall result from
them we use that document to 64 came out
in 1936 misstep document to 64 and says
countless human ills in from the fact
that impoverished solid officience all
of America no longer provides plant
foods with the mineral elements
essential for human and nourishment
health they do that 1936 was published
in the US Senate document 1060 for
profanity hearings the agricultural
department and armours and university
best Romantic poets we're having all
these testimonies and they put all the
dead in this document but not like they
haven't known it because in time for 264
1936 well
I know that happen but not only do we
converge electricity instead it would
know would anyone in the garden anymore
but what about the bigger fields well
what were prior to electricity what were
the most expensive and the most fertile
farmlands bottom land mile and things
like flood plains now what would happen
to these flood plains and bottom land
the moon valleys along the sides what
would happen here but it flooded that
water flood waters receipt what a leave
behind so where's her minerals from
mountains hundreds of making the
thousands of miles upstream then partner
push that silt off the side before he
planted he plowed back in every year he
would greedy and not leave the soil with
those memories but people like
electricity was safe it was inexpensive
it was predictable saved a lot of house
fires what do they look they standard
all date on off on off of just quite a
thing
all I just think but electric spills
electric refrigerators you didn't have
to wait for some guy waiting to bring
much ice blocks but put your house with
a straw around and keep it from melting
I remember that piece remember that
right and it's old politicians jumped in
with it you know for me I electrified
the Tennessee Valley in 3000 - do you
have the TVA for 8000 top electrify the
Tennessee Valley he wrote for me
electrify the southwestern seven states
including California and Arizona Nevada
the Hoover Dam create thousands job they
did I mean everybody's excited I mean
everybody got electric blender electric
mixer an electric stove electric icebox
I mean they have TVs and didn't have
been grindin troll anymore was electric
why don't you think about it change
everything there's an unintended
consequence flood control no more playin
no more silt to plow and every year when
we get for them we've got the Dust Bowl
the Great Depression
so the saw was dead no food he was sick
the quest couldn't work factories shut
down all the industrialized all went
into a funk because electricity I'm sure
old tom says when turnover is great
realized what his invention hadn't done
not because he knew that was going to
happen but here's a case where they
should have sat down said okay
the consequences of everything we do
here be so globally encompassing what
what we expect we had to deal with okay
that's why we have higher inspectors and
buildings now you know you make your
whole building on tissue paper
insulation the electric wires are under
your tissue paper about to have a fire
that doesn't work okay so you have to
think ahead what does your invention
gonna create
our doctors have a disc inception when
you have abundance you don't worry about
nutritional deficiency if everybody has
a loaf of bread you have to worry about
nutritional deficiencies everybody has
it's made every day to worry about
nutritional deficiencies that's not true
how many minerals are in this wheat
field here here they weren't here yeah
they're here this one you know the
minerals are in veins that look like
this when farming we know that's true
and so we give every animal everything
we know they need to maximize the
production why don't you have 100
calories you're feeding they just give
her hay and some grain given a grain if
you do that what's gonna happen is
another 100 times repeating every year
30 of them will have miscarriages and
premature births will have birth defects
and thirty one hundred cans go out of
business next year so they don't know
insurance
so we give them four pennies a day every
Newton we know they need all nine
essential nutrients read all that in
each town has a perfect calf they live
too and very efficiently to either
market weight or to reproductive age
about the need for veterinary care
that's the ideal goal we've done it
we've done an animal so they don't have
insurance
why should it count you a cup of milk we
she had to give a gallon of milk for the
same amount of pee I get it an added
vitamins minerals I have been wondered I
don't know how many watch Olympics and
World Games and things like that and
always fascinated me we have runners
like Jim Fixx with a six foot four I
mean user darling in the medical field
because he said he won't supplement his
exercise and keep her hard to clean I
mean this guy had more records around
the world and he dropped dead at 52
didn't even make it take you to die
attain your throw it in the air exactly
I want you to appreciate who was it and
still yet today who is it the wins most
long distant race of like marathons some
little Ethiopian is 411 way 92 pounds
tell me is Bronson like this big
six-foot seven of Shriners you know
they're dropping dead all along the way
why did that little guy from Ethiopia
always win the marathon that really
fascinated me pathologist well here's
why I put this picture Thomas Edison
beside this picture here on your left
this is a static picture 100 miles up
this is Southern California agricultural
and Pacific Ocean over here makes going
on here you rebel over here Salton Sea
so you know exactly resisted at this is
a small Salt Lake about one-tenth the
size of the Great Salt Lake did you talk
what I want you to see here is the
nutritional minerals in aeterna uniform
later on goes here they occur in veins
like Chopin Chalker Blythe train so
soybeans of sweets has grown here and
here and here and there and here and
here there
remember there's like 200 square miles
here and there and here and there and
here they're not gonna all have the same
amount in variety of minutes again the
intercourse on to say we know we have to
give them everything they need perfectly
to make their genes DNA RNA and telling
us happy to give maximum production
maximum longevity maximum have help in
humans we is evil possess what doctors
tell us to do they trained dietitians
playing what this percentage of
carbohydrate in this percentage of
proteins and fans wear that do for
miners mineral nothing that's why we're
most obese nation in the world or no one
and then that make you feel warm and
fuzzy ok just about ready get to the
bottom line hurry up or slice left after
this one I think it's worth reminding
you here as we go onto these next ones
very important yeah I say it's part of
Agriculture came out this was 2012 I'm
said
howdy five-cent Americans are merely
division going back 100 years to 1914
and medals were so over the past hundred
years complete by 85% okay this is NZ is
had not been CC for way back in 1936 our
farms all complete about a million a
result our Boozer literally started
researching medicine medicine medicine
cannot compensate for this deficiency
how many nutrients is in Prozac how many
nutrients was in lipitor how many new
friends ridden digitalis we're beginning
to get the picture yeah okay this is a
court of everything we do in Young Duty
is a compost pile of thousands and
thousands of years old
mm-hmm there's 100 cubic miles of this
stuff nobody else has access to this
except young kitty we have this in
perpetuity for as long as the earth is
alive we have this nobody else has it
100 cubic miles of it these guys are
standing on a road that is 3,000 foot
elevation above sea level and that 25
foot cap up here a limestone and we do
its brain limestone for the animal
fossils and the other puzzle from the
ocean so you know this stuff's been
under the ocean for thousands and
thousands of years
it's totally a pollution-free has 78
medals including all 60 essential
minerals and proper ratios totally
organic have no pollution it because
been under the ocean for thousand years
so it's been protected listen he has all
nine rivers including the six students
vetted for doubling lifespans every year
including this one June 27th we're going
to give a tour we take about ten bus
loads out there 50 people in a bus and
limestone cab again see this stuff here
this compost this is some of the lines
going chopped off the top we can make a
pyramid of that stuff right and these
are some of our so shits and
distributors who really appreciate this
to go out there and when you go out
there you know there's a guy do you see
the stuff you know God exists color
questions here when do you put on your
car before the engine burns up or as the
engine burns up
that's kind of a giggle question on ask
a do you have a young couple who's
getting engaged or maybe they're kind of
running together real hot and you know
you know something's gonna happen right
are they getting engagement getting
married instead of giving them 200 bucks
to start a household instead of giving
them instead of monogrammed towels
instead of giving them a set of linens
to start their house
give them the 90 substitutions for both
me and her I can't do this I'm doing
this because we know how to vent every
birth defects you can name it ten times
that many don't know about I always want
to have a special-needs child when you
prevent it why would you want to have a
baby barber Down syndrome cleft palates
spina bifida it's real palsy heart
defects much history since red roses
missing letters too many fingers all
that kind of stuff
why would you want that to happen it was
totally a mess we've eliminated all
those birth defects and animals
including behavioral things transgenders
amen lesbian women asexual people
they're like crazy aunt Ruthie who died
a spinster nineteen everyone on a date
great example frankly never went on a
date with me he loved him to kind of
babysit your house we went on vacation
these sort of behavioral problems are
preventable now he can't fix them you
can't pray them back into the bottle you
can't put the genie back in the bottle
but they're preventable it's preventable
all vertie facts are preventable
many of them are reversible and the
babies weren't but including things that
I call invar tears metabolism
lactose intolerance we can make up the
difference with enzymes is preventable
single cell anemia is it in or an urban
tablet this time genetic impacts the
occurs in white people too but you can't
have a black and white people say well
the thalassemia and white people that's
how many of you Elysee be white people a
sickle cell anemia might people say busy
but you can't call it that close you
can't have doesn't fit the theory right
that's what I was running into another
homeless outside and saying I'm pulling
my hair out saying everything they're
saying is not true there's that there's
a problem here I didn't have a name
epigenetics at that point but I knew
something that's what my folks in the
Smithsonian Institute because I was
pointing out these problems in 1971 that
1200 pages but everybody kind of laughed
at me at that time but as the years went
by the oh my god Wally was right okay so
you prevent all this stuff especially if
you have other children what happens
when a couple has a special-needs child
they have three normal kids before them
where's all the energy the money and
time go there's a special in each child
and that caused all kinds of Christian
with the kids and problem them and they
could get in real trouble
did you drugs they commit suicide to do
all kinds of weird stuff
attention for the special detail of
those special needs kids
once you have one they don't need to
have one it's not genetic doesn't just
happen it is preventable
okay to me that's the most important
thing cuz I became a physician if I
could kill somebody and so it just got
to be a bigger project than I'd imagined
we have 800 projects and young Jimmy
have 800 different programs we do with
over 900 different diseases we have a
program for each one of them I prevent I
reverse them how to mention better than
is currently being managed my favorite
programs are the ones that give you all
90 cents we have about 25 and then my
favorite of the favorites is a healthy
start pack we have two versions we have
the original then we'd have a 2.0 which
is a kind of update switched out a
couple of degrees because some people
were kind of maybe allergic to shellfish
and things like that which is in this
one but are not in 2.0 kind of thing so
because we do that that's where
everything was there we made two
versions of bacon this contains 245
nutrients it gives you all perfect
fixation of $0.90 solutions incorporated
for a hundred pound a minute less for a
month so you give this a 100 pound
person pretty good for a month divided
in half half those
there's a 50 pound kid or 50 pound
Spanish veggie booze party years old
these case this will last two months but
nothing else matters except the body
weight okay
then this is a 200 pound first you have
to give to these one full dose or
anything breakfast my clothes to be
there and 400 pound pastor he had to
take four of those a day plus the ASAP
drop secret under the tongue it speeds
up the metabolism and he was losing four
pounds a day
he never had any surgery could all his
in tighten up as soon as he lost weight
and according we have miss Michigan here
yeah how many been on the product here
all right every day I was waking up I
had the drainage and sneezing and
itching in the ear thing every year I
had cold
I had one cold almost four years
[Music]
okay 25 prepared programs so you don't
have to think about much you just do it
says to do they're all based on the
Healthy Start pact which I just showed
you don't have to take the Healthy Start
pact in the program this is at the core
you look you can see that the Healthy
Start package at the core of each one of
these things I would use the healthy
blood sugar packed bar thank you I guess
one guy here hi Jude ideas at one time
issue just reduce your medications your
doctors have taught you to do a blusher
drop barrel type one diabetic so we're
never be able to totally get off of this
one the available reduced by 90% they'll
be able to cut your time the day you
need to check your blood sir from maybe
six or eight times a day to maybe once
or twice complications go away and
you'll live 350 years longer an amazing
no complication type to dive in shoes
within two weeks to two months or next
back pay how long do you understand the
90 essential nutrients oh my god next
week next year five years from now fifty
years from now those minerals still not
being sought to have to take it forever
right or life I'd like oxygen water hope
you like to use a healthy long joint
pack part well I do PDI's your process
I'm sure try some different friends
going to arthritis ruin charts Rajesh
Khanna's throw into either a group of
herbs that kill bugs or the minocycline
the type of cycling antibiotic that
kills the middle cycling or the unity
kills the Michael play of the bug that
contributes to the cause of room cars
fries
and then there are some very bouncy
periodontal disease is osteoporosis is a
face why do you think little people look
like little people because they lose the
bone in their facing a receding company
you loose teeth and dense this will put
implants in them give them dentures you
get mine healthy one giant pack their
teeth tighten up like you put cement
around as suppose to come to come back
up cuz the phones come back and they
look this is why these ladies look 2530
years younger than they are because they
haven't had out the approaches of the
things it makes sense yeah little people
of men and women look older as they lose
the bone in their face people forget you
don't get cos yukos's now if you eat it
just your legs and your hips your rib
here vertebrae it's everywhere including
your skull in your job I could have
never talked about that they should be
put in jail it's like never telling you
it's alluded to lubricate the bearings
in your front wheels
I just keep burning up
and then of course there is a
sarcoidosis there is five of myalgia
there's lupus same thing healthy bone
joint packet in gluten-free diet bone
spurs kidney stones the one that I love
is when I have kidney stones the first
thing in a medical doctor which is no
tells him I stopped calcium supplements
no dairy
you should be put in jail for that
because I didn't have kidney stones you
have raging osteoporosis all those
kidney stones came from your bones not
from your diet and your parathyroid
landfill enlarged oh we got secret
parathyroid glands out now they're just
working like you're working a muscle
carrying buckets of milk well let's cut
your arms off cause you're getting
because you're carrying bunch of buckets
of milk you can put in jail for that
they disable you when they take your
parathyroid glands out all you had to do
is take the hell to go on a giant pack
your blood calcium which should be
between eight point five to ten point
five milligrams per deciliter place is
25 that Creek stocker to all you guys
stop calcium you got unhealthy bone and
joint pack within weeks comes down to
eight because all that calcium would
pull tighter going by your parathyroid
overworking why is it they don't teach
physiology in medical schools they spend
all the time teaching them how to send
you a bill first thing they walk in the
door any master name is how are you
okay healthy digestion belching burping
bloating constipation diarrhea partying
college sucks
there's no such thing as asking reflux
reflux alright this is one of the failed
medical theories really no such thing is
asked to reflux
yeah reflux is lack of acid reflux your
stomach environment should be a pH of
1.2 1.5 one thing most acid 14 be the
most out from 17 neutral her stomach
department should be 1.2 1.5 very very
very very acid and it gets about three
or four moving towards neutral 7 yeast
and bacteria begin to grow in there and
when you eat carbohydrates ensured the
in the permit is just like making beer
or wine in your stomach lots of gas
heartburn reflux you get your stomach
acid down to one point two again reflux
stops immediately so why would I want to
just take antacid well you take in
essence you take proton pump inhibitors
and stop something has production but
then the next five years going to have
20 new diseases you didn't have because
you won't be able to absorb any
nutrients you need an acid environment
to digest proteins down into
the USS because they're pepsin won't
work without mana we won't be able to
absorb vitamin b12 and won't be able to
absorb minerals without an acid
environment why do people have to go
every months get a b12 shot by their
doctor or their doctor said no salt and
you can't make some against without salt
salt is aroma chiral next time yes I
remember so you go in every month to get
a deep well injection because their
intrinsic factor won't work without an
acid environment your stomach all these
are doctor caused diseases
remember only dead doctors don't lie
healthy pain mark back how they ran a
hard pack we're talking about all is
saying here there's five different
dimensions doctors always built our
counselor disease because it paid most
rounds no mercy they never built for the
other for you guys they know you gotta
take over the one they're videotaping
most of our authorization
there's bastard immense we have pledged
our in the brain but of course cost and
Rovers a deficiency of a single
bottomczek wernicki courts counselors as
efficient environment plus M estimate
was a b12 deficiency to mention there's
nails nor zebras in the cholesterol
efficiency and then of course there is
hunting disease heart disease
Lou Gehrig's disease MS all those are
the brain diseases and then there's
congestive heart failure card about the
emergencies hurry artists need and
trauma tokens and thrombotic RER disease
okay
as they take this and I would throw in
also the ultimate daily tablet and to
help support healthy blood strokes
through obstructed art I would also use
this for a kidney failure also we here I
throw in the aromatherapy oil from
ancient legacy I put in peppermint oil
char remember one o'clock in the morning
Master Hunter okay from the oldest black
Baptist Church in Fort Wayne Indiana we
were talking to him for his diabetes and
his tire problems he played basketball
in university big six-foot-five guy very
slim his wife would sit next to me and
char was sitting across from me his wife
was going but I mean every 10 second
she's belching and burping she's a
pastor's wife so I can't be rude to her
one live good morning I'm trying to do
with his bad business arthritis and she
said their urban taught you my ear which
I said ma'am Halloween Eve and
uncomfortable like this my lips don't
say anything else like there is this I
know I said never tried pedimental
because they have they have to have some
in my pocket I am yeah even hit right
now I have ever not okay and very fair
like these all of the doctor quarters
too much acid and peppermint oh don't
take pepper
and it smell great that right yeah and
so I went you know in the lobby the
hotel one five good morning got these
machines with a hot water the coffee in
the D campus I drew up a hot water click
or drops the peppermint oil in there and
I said just spell it don't drink it
don't drink you just smell it I'm
looking at him with one eye talking to
him about his diabetes nurse rice I'm
looking at her the other iron chameleon
right she's going you can tell she's
smelling it and she's already starting
to burp and felt less she couldn't
resist anymore she took a sip and I show
you what happened and as God is my
witness charm I wish you there she goes
immediately just like 10 seconds it's
we've been using this when people with
acid reflux ever since we have a we have
an enzyme with stomach acid in it all of
it enzymes oh my gosh I'm gonna get rid
of it
reflux aka answer replies it really
should be called lack of acid reflux now
once you know what it is nobody should
ever go to a gastroenterologist again
have an endoscopic instrument with
bounty and kill you but they can't clean
them we read that newspaper he bleeds a
damn
yo people right left and center oh let's
all have that done
okay got one more slide and then you
guys can give them okay you knew your
drawing let me do one more slide here
and then after they do the drawing on
answer questions for 30 minutes then we
got to run our travels tell you're not
yet over
remember we have programs for 900
different diseases the program's over
900 diseases including prevention and
reversals but 85% of us you can run into
will be taken care of by these four
major programs it doesn't matter you
cannot hurt anybody it's not like a
pursuit you didn't run for school
somebody hurt you give to pursue those
guys polypharmacy
kill them okay in this case you can't
hurt with you I hit people who all they
do they tell us that they have our
Reisner need we give them the healthy
bone and joint pact when they come back
to my seminars Ranjan but I'm just
really amazed that my I would like to
make your generation that one way to
legally glad for six eight 10 years and
in 1983 2025 lenses we do the thousands
of times a month when we learn how
what's going on but they're telling us
this sort of said what and one doctor
called me a liar when he said then I
made a little wager with them make a
long story short yeah yep and and he
brought me 27 charts the next day all
these people were legally blind for six
eight 10 years
a generation and he said he would take
all 27 and pay for someone's when I
failed he was going to destroy me okay
let's go for it he was kind of shocked
that I was that casual about it and so
you need a papal supplement I wrote down
exactly what he had to do it I have to
give credit he did it as I said in 90
days here examine them all all all 27
could read 20 20 after 90 days
well you required last 25 didn't require
glasses so is it apologize no need to
take on a nerd stand up the restaurant
apologize the human restaurant instead
he did something better he made me a CD
called seeing is believing told the
story
that's the c-d-c believe he came from
and every here it's about 12 years ago
and he called me a liar in front of 300
people so you get a little pressurized -
right Mary and so better than that he
made the CD for me
every year I sell millions own lots of
heart tissue stuff bones cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue just
between the vertebrae that kind of stuff
healthy one giant a soft tissue heart
brain liver kidneys lung muscles even
soft tissue healthy random heart pack
what do you do for bless your bones
diabetes type 2 diabetes type 1 anxiety
panic attacks narcolepsy which we can
call the reactive hypoglycemia a lot of
times
it'll cause things like depression make
oppression by 4z that kind of stuff
ad ADHD will contribute to autism
healthy blood sugar package how the
digestion pack okay when you have that
Jessica this is not difficult we're
talking about reflux okay we're talking
about constipation diarrhea belching
burping bloating farting heartburn we're
talking about your bowel syndrome
inflammatory bowel disease we're talking
about colitis ultralights crohn's
disease
you know gluten-free diet you get on the
healthy digestion impact going to have a
half three theater intestine removed for
Crohn's disease we do this thousands of
time here it comes if you get rid of
it's not on your disease is they gluten
intolerance you get them on a
gluten-free diet to give them the
support foot digestive system all goes
away
sure are you seen that heaven June
you've seen that heaven oh yeah oh yeah
no problem
Andrea is she a miracle isn't people
your work he wasn't haven't you okay now
I have to tell you I learned about the
network marketing is there's only about
two minutes I learned about the network
marketing thing when I first graduated
school 1978
school in a purlin argument argument
makes medic doctors way back then 36
years ago for primary care physicians as
well as a primary care physician and I
started lecturing up and down Highway
five and I'd get 300 new patients a week
I couldn't handle in my office
Oh brandy doctor I just didn't have
everything you know I better practice
existing practice I didn't have all the
patients I'm getting 300 patients a week
for my lectures and so I was giving a
free lecture every Tuesday night for one
hour and these 300 people will sometimes
be 500 people come to my lectures
because I was going to tell them why I
was different what i was doing
differently what I expected from them
from the nutritional standpoint what to
do with her diet and so I realized and
it dawned on me as suddenly now I'm
doing 400 hours worth of work in one
hour she didn't having to spend an hour
in each patient training them I'm
training 400 of them in one hour I'm
doing 400 dollars worth of work in one
hour but I can train a whole bunch of
people to do the same thing I'll be able
to do thousands of people per hour
thousands of hours work and so now every
month I pay 250,000 piays physician's
assistants to do what I can show you
what to do here on a bad day through
their eyes I see about 2 million
patients on a good day see about 5
million patients through their office
charge sees about 500,000 years old and
one lady who seen 900,000 patients every
day through through her system of piays
and through all computers all I kind of
stuff as for these books come from I
mean
it's so much dammit we've got three more
new books coming out of here in the next
couple months okay
give you the information the accumulator
so we're looking for help we're growing
we're seeing 10,000 new patients a month
now it's like going crazy ugly trade if
we get stock options we give car bonuses
look at thousand dollars a month yep
it's pretty nice Porsche for that purse
ad whatever you want right and this is a
will bull a step he worked for a company
for 30 years you will your job your kid
you sell your job when you're retirement
to somebody no but you spend a couple
hours a week doing your young shitty
program and helping other people I will
pay you haven't seen amount of money yep
you don't need to go to school for one
day I'm gonna train you for nothing
how's that you only have to pay a post
sale for all the products how's that you
get on auto-ship you're in a spaceship
you save another 80% I'll pay the
shipping if you get an auto ship okay
okay watch you guys come on up here
[Music]
three two six seven seven
6 3 2 6 1 2 0 pitch em up doctors don't
lie
three to six one one nine three to six
one one time thank you don't get up
another DVD from dr. dead doctors don't
lie
three two six zero five eight DVD by dr.
with what supplements to take and why
three two six zero five three
three two six zero six one one more to
go labels on how to use herbs
how many you are not already using how
many are not already oh good so where we
got here tonight make sure you sign up
with them how many came from newspaper
radio raise your hand okay cool well he
sure doesn't eat his true justice from
there
okay very simple are you wearing makeup
right now okay I know you're severely
nearly deficient from here now how I
know that sharp white there's also he
have white hair white hair we have a
copper deficiency also gonna have also
always going to have spider veins
varicose veins yes you we were doing
this it doesn't matter like this hope
you're going to have a varicose veins
and hemorrhoids which your varicose
veins in a funny place right and then
you'll also get aneurysms you get a
breakdown the elastic fibers on walls
here arteries and veins you can die
suddenly from a tourism up here aneurysm
down here yeah now you already have an
injury
so you're the like any educational and
this is worth - isn't going to take the
thing that gives away a gluten
intolerance without tests because the
test is a biopsy retest me you don't
like that there's risk involved but if
you have celiac disease you have
appendicitis diverticulitis there
revolves on your own time for a bowel
disease colitis or Crohn's disease you
have eczema dermatitis arises rosacea if
you have a history of six eight ten
twelve diseases they're all nutritional
efficient yeah well you have a bunch of
them because you already told me you
have aneurysm you have things I yeah you
have a carotid artery problem right I
already have varicose vein you have
oh yeah you told me yesterday a little
bit doesn't matter it's all reversible
this hub main priority take the healthy
brain and heart pack it all goes away
within months your hair coming back now
the book is gonna give you what you
wanted to know what you a chance there
what do I do for a diagnosis that I want
to go to doctor number one can actually
call a nurse practitioner and talk about
them there's a closely doctor I would do
that but which one do is beautiful that
book let's play doctor and looking I
believe it's chapter seven it's a whole
laboratory chapter it'll tell you how to
go to your pharmacy without a
prescription you know the same test
strips your doctor we use in his office
for a two thousand dollar physical you
get the same test strips for blood test
why would you want in your permanent
record that you have pre-diabetes or
metabolic syndrome or type it up is not
going to get promotions your insurance
goes up and everybody's looking at you a
little bit I think we should already
have this genetic disease a genetic but
they think
right when you you did it yourself you
don't need to go to doctor for diagnosis
of diabetes you stick yourself in the
finger you're on the test against the
rain going by to get on the photo
machine to read it and I'll tell you if
your blush is about 100 or not you know
you're on 600 glucose tolerance test to
see if you have reactive lysine your
narcolepsy okay if you have pain in your
knee the others already have arthritis
you need to have a doctor say oh you
have already it doesn't matter see your
thumb doesn't matter if your wrist your
elbow your neck okay the one I love are
things like Tigra eight the atrial
fibrillation and major tribulation is
what's called peripheral neuropathy it's
not about heart disease at all these
regulation where you get a palpitation
of your heart you might even get
tachycardia rapid heart rate the heart
weird happens in your ventricular to get
ventricular tachycardia it's not a heart
problem and doctors we want to put in
pacemakers and we'll put in
defibrillators it's not going to work
because amount of heart cause the back
problem what happens is when you get
these inner disk disease the disken
thicker the Berbick it closed again and
they smashed the roots to the spinal
nerves coming out from between thoracic
arrays one two three four those founders
control the rate rid of your heart
you're getting pinched because the
vertebra you're getting closer and
closer together
the doctor said oh you got eight bit man
I got to give you all these blood
thinners you're going to get you're
going to get black pine you know if you
get a blood clot I didn't make sense in
the fish okay and so we wanted to do is
avoid the next step of course which is
ablation when kill portion is your heart
to see they can find the places running
them up so you just slow down your heart
that's not good work
not a hard problem survivors next they
do is call the arrest or the
electrocution is death and hope to
reboot your heart rhythm last night at
work because it's not a heart problems
backbone the next thing on the list is
our transplant all together they're
going to get $500,000 for our procedures
that's none of our problems a back
problem same theme an herbal bladder
syndrome we and how many offenders fell
to get urgency can empty your bladder I
got many women and particularly call me
all the time say I've had UTI urinary
tract infection for 25 years I've been
on antibiotics every day for 25 years
that will personally do this for your
doctor he's either very stupid should
have license taken away from him or he's
a criminal and he's milking you like an
ATM machine one of the other go okay
because you have a lower back home don't
you oh yeah I doubt that
well of course they did but they didn't
need to do surgery you lucked out
surviving I know but you're not
listening to me that's called a
prayerful neuropathy always have any way
you had spinal stenosis or he has
something that nature is squeezing in
the spinal cord and are smelling or if
your lumbar area which close relation to
parallel what they do with a Chuck
surgeon my mom's are bowing out take the
pressure off thinner but in a current
lumbar area yeah
and so now your legs work that's not a
miracle that just kind of like rotor
Rudy the root side of a sewer when it's
in my blood you know their employment
tree roots your blender bathtub okay and
so it's just a mechanical treatment they
really even solve the problem okay
because their problems really have
osteoporosis they've had that kind of
problem going on peripheral neuropathy
okay another one I love is in women wake
up at night six times go to the bathroom
and take a thief now you get their mom
well I guarantee is not a prostate
problem first name oh you got somebody
that might take me as possible I'm a
girl
oh don't even think about it peripheral
neuropathy squeezing the nerves of
control of ladder okay so you still have
some problems but you still have a
problem right so that background so
you're a perfect candidate for the
healthy bone joint Pat what do you weigh
okay so you need to the healthy one
giant packs per month well most other
thing twice a day then immediately we
should take in each case you get a jar
of what we call Sam cream which is an
analgesic a pain reliever an
anti-inflammatory
cream I want you to get from our ancient
Lakes a division what we call trauma oil
but six drops of trauma while in a
teaspoon of that
Sam cream put that on your lumbar area
particularly you have the surgery okay
around your neck okay but put on your
lumbar area also right now in the middle
of you so any other side oftentimes
they'll be giving up symptomatic relief
that you won't be waking up the middle
of night but relieve the inflammation
around the roots of those nerves I take
it four to six months and I can legally
say to support and promote maintenance
repair Carly Lehman
and that conditioning discipline the
invertebrate phone makes upon itself and
it will currently go away okay we
avoided surgery millions of times here
because you see you still have a lot of
problems even though your legs are
working which is very very good but
there's also a risk of danger aren't you
think about how much you think about
Joan Rivers her voice is changing and so
she went into a storefront clinic in
California a storefront plenty to put
under general anesthesia oh they forgot
to turn on the oxygen she's bringing
them she died at age 81 okay no smoking
okay so you get the idea Oh Mary - it
I'll give room charts rise we want to
take the healthy body join Pack 1 400
pounds of body weight w 8 & 3 then take
one for each aren't proper body weight
so the 15 to 20 glue glue jello day 5 a
breakfast lunch dinner and bedtime right
what Charmaine what do you weigh
and if I can hear you okay so how much
high glucose L do you take a day you're
taking 3 cheating and 12 pounds your
weight right so why do they throw in
what shark ASAP and get to drop get two
bottles an ASAP for dropper pull out of
your tongue 30 minutes before your meal
and a second driver pull out of your
time 59 for you let absorbs your
audition don't swallow in Virginia
swallow it but we'll get the best result
and within a couple of days we'll start
losing a half pound into time they
needed four pounds a day
utilize 101 911 and bet on their
products yeah yeah
and so yeah what you want to do there's
two ways you can do it not like there's
actually three ways yeah I like the
called killer body a guy his size it's
him - oh you okay well you would need
you need 12 from the color Valley today
for breakfast woods in there there being
three bottles a month of this summer
body is a blend of eight earth as for
your business and plus two of them
actually have antimicrobial properties
and killed off bacteria including
Michael Desmond right and then of course
there's minocycline which is a
tetracycline category antibody which
will kill a bug also some people have to
do both they like to do that you know
cycling and the killer body so it goes
through your choices right and and
licensed in California
I really should see patients like
yourself right right prescriptive eco
need to go to some nurse practitioner
write you a prescription with
minocycline because it's actually in the
vertical okay to take you know cycling
I've been trying I'm trying to get you
their attention from the beginning I've
been trying to cut talk to you for a lot
of years okay I've got your book
Little Red Sea - okay so - I was a
American longevity a long time ago yeah
and I was taking the orange the orange
90 essentially started getting kidney
stones doctors taking me off that all
that because you know you can't have all
the warns on I have Kenny stone now
every two weeks I just had a five
millimeter come out this morning with a
little bunch behind it and just kill
them - are you ready stop yeah okay now
are you wearing makeup
are you always think like that always
kind of pink there's no what I'm asking
you sorry cheeks always kind of pink
yeah okay II got realization okay I can
see from here you got realization this
means you have gluten intolerance you
must be gluten free because they have
gluten intolerance you're only absorbing
ten to fifteen percent which and take in
that's why you're having a problem
you must be gluten free like you gotta
be free the dog the cat the burden the
finishing because most dog foods and
captain's auto food issues especially
dry foods have grains in them which are
gluten everybody in the house including
the dog in the can the burden the fish
spouse mother-in-law everybody gotta be
gluten free otherwise you're not going
what do you do for a living
don't tell me you're working Panera
Bread
you do what door-to-door sales about
what what do you sell construction stuff
okay so you're not working with bread
and you know and I messed up but I hire
you for living
okay paperwork to me so it doesn't
matter I'm not absorbing it though yeah
okay so then Shh please then we should
take what you weigh but to 20 to 35 okay
so once you take two I hope that random
heart passion month okay I want you to
take an extra bottle of Asti oh they
take three ounces a day out so how's the
breakfast lunch and dinner
and then I want you to get to two large
files of Luca gel so you take 15 of
those today five at breakfast private
launch five at dinner okay but you got
to get drop-dead gluten-free everything
you have in the house Mel don't just say
well we'll use it up give it to a church
get a tax deduction get out tonight bag
it up tonight
every grocery store has a gluten free
aisle we have gluten free meals it's in
our go foods division which have a 25
year shelf life and so I would be
getting some of those things they have
around in case there's a breakdown in
The Drifter all pause - all that stuff
anything made from wheat brother Otto's
there is no such thing as gluten free
oats the gluten in hope and hope Neil is
hopefully added but still you know look
by any other name still blue and half go
sweet brother right that means beer
Scotch bourbon drink rye whiskey over a
milkshake and milkshakes are okay but
milk Multan those are not where they
make multi-dose from Malta dry I have
been drinking milk and it doesn't matter
I'm educating a whole roomful of people
I don't care if you don't breathe I'm
educating
so I'm not answering your question I
answer your question for all of them
okay so cool your jets okay so if you're
not doing something that I'm saying be
worried about then you have to worry
about because you're already not doing
it right so now this is for life does
not so you just feel good all of this
for the rest your life
now Jenny brothers and sisters you got
to tell them cuz they're gluten
intolerant - and the girls your sisters
your girl cousins from your mom's side
are all passing this on to their kids
they say after warning how do you have a
family meeting whether it's on your
phone or telephone conference for
everybody it's the only going to do it
once
if you do not do this I would get them
all present for the birthdays of
Christmas it's called serial killers
tells you all this hidden places you
find gluten how do you think Cracker
Barrel and Denny's holds a meatloaf and
meatballs together wheat flour okay how
do they think of gravy wheat flour
how does Denny's and IHOP fluff up their
omelets and their families
I just read their menus they tell you
they put a pancake batter and waffle
batter and their love and their omelets
and their scrambled eggs to fluff them
up so you're not just getting ate a lot
of those places when you go to the face
at least 60% oil and so they look like
scrambled eggs or they're 60% well 20%
dry date powder and 20% wheat flour you
in one of those places and these
beautiful good tasting scrambled eggs
are puffed up say okay these eggs come
from a partner a plastic bag or they are
these crack cages
if I want to see the shelves again to be
obsessive otherwise you will kill
yourself okay so what about like so eat
flour and all that I don't give a rat's
tail about soy flour has nothing to do
it lets in all the stuff down to it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter if
you're not allergic you so I doesn't
matter your largest I don't eat it so I
won't hurt you if you're not allergic to
it
what do you eat it for I can see it
okay now okay he didn't have a beer with
other buddy and say how do I talk this
woman into this I need Mercedes so I
actually had pictures of a gal who'd
have done things like you have only they
were like two inches in diameter like
the garden hose yeah here's her club but
I'm talk about the veins which I can see
from here let me take these two inches
in diameter down to less than size of a
lead and a lead pencil less than
millimeter to matter you had your chance
now you gotta be quiet okay so I know
but you also have varicose veins okay
you want to get you and get better or
you want to keep talking please don't
battle with me I'm giving you a million
dollars
free advice I'm gonna have to start
charging people in a speech I'm a
question yeah there has to be pain for
breaking the rules
hey all right so why don't you do anyway
1:30 okay I want you to take one healthy
brain and heart pack per month
an extra bottle same for the one should
take six a day three breakfast treat
dinner in this land half the dose of
everything else twice a day then I want
you to take what we call ultimate daily
tablets okay what you take through those
two I say maybe one about a month okay
that's to support growing healthy
vascular health or cohesion also
including arteries also because see what
that's happening you're late guess
what's happening in your neck it's
happening here real is your heart is
happening in your eyes and how many your
brain and I just haven't laid but you
notice all this bastard mom what's the
color of her hair it doesn't matter it
has nothing but during age I see kids
who are ten years old with a hair wider
than yours there's white as you know
their hair is as white as sheets but in
six months time it goes back to their
normal color but I love my white hair
it's going to change
because when it changes that means your
arteries are opening up in addition to
the HDH shows you in addition to the
ultimate daily tablets three twice day
and one by one I also want you to get
two bottles of HGH a th three letters
Harry
George Harry hdh wells a month one
should take six to those at breakfast
and sixty dinner time so take a little
while to do that but their little
castles so it's kind of easy and take a
whisk through that rather than water
table water be this bit with water right
it slosh around but every you can t take
just with a half a teaspoon some food
and swallow the food and the capsule
together it won't kill filled up with
water the purpose of this is of course
took for your lining of your arteries to
make nitric oxide let's do what valets
your arteries it's kind of using things
with when you have you're having chest
pain nitroglycerin actually releases
nitric oxide in your arteries is done
the same thing without prescription okay
now we have to stop the ongoing damage
we have to change everything you've been
doing because what you've been doing cuz
she's probably no fried foods I don't
care I don't care I I'm careful where
the landmines I want no fried food no
processed meat the nitrates nitrites me
savage meets massages ham bacon blowing
sighing pepperoni jerky no hi walk
overall margin Manny's undressing
they're giving me that look okay these
metal ions are they oxidize turn into
trans fatty acids header cytokines
acrylamide complain their arteries in
your veins and clog your arteries and
veins no oils I just love my Italian
virgin virgin virgin virgin virgin
virgin virgin birth virgin olive oil
kill you here don't do it anymore then
Ashley drop dead no gluten in the
household you your spouse dog cat
mother-in-law sister renter anyway in
the household got any gluten free
otherwise you're not going to pretty
have to absorb these new things from the
work okay okay got time for two more oh
you already had a question trooper
are you together yeah okay can't yes
ma'am my son that is 25 years old these
victims with Lyme disease polyol just
within the last month by the he hasn't
symptoms of it for like two years
he started with hair loss and it started
with losing weight
join me and he finally went to a doctor
and they did the test for Lyme disease
and they said he has it so we can to
test redone and they'd never been to the
Rocky Mountains are up okay well he
doesn't have Lyme disease now advanced
you tell more questions here you ever
have asthma or bronchitis no you ever
have bowel problems constipation
diarrhea complaints with a colicky baby
yeah he told you every time did you
breastfeed him yeah okay are you wearing
makeup
yes okay do you have any skin tone
eczema dermatitis for us as a rosacea
no okay no respiratory problems okay
what about Andrew - okay let's see here
have any brothers and sisters
yeah have any animal you know pennytown
or you know that you know that
did they any of them have skin problems
no her sister's in there nobody have
rough skin on the back of their arms no
your son has gluten intolerance that
means you have it where you gave it to
him okay men get it but they can't pass
it on they don't have pregnancy breasts
yeah I can make that happen if you want
this way
please don't
he needs beyond he needs beyond the two
healthy brain and heart pax romana
great see how the brain works for months
and then I want him to get on the march
Allium to those five says one bottle
month and that's to get stem cells going
right three build stuff I also want him
to get two bottles of Luca gel to learn
algebra Patel has to support promote
makes repair cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue disks between the
vertebra phone maker gonna sell and
let's see here last one we have a
destress capsules through those five
days 2,000 bucks
and I want you to call me every two
weeks and tell me what's his name
max okay I want you to tell me every two
weeks House Energy is doing how his pain
his knees and only how so snow right now
realize he doesn't have Lyme disease
because Lyme disease is curable in two
weeks
yes it's terrible in two weeks I get
people talking five heck I'm glad she's
really quietly that my antennae go from
they take Heinlein's me how long have
you had over 25 years I've been on a
bike for 25 years weird doctor dzj
nobody never did the I don't care he
doesn't have Lyme disease just you know
people get some antibodies against
tuberculosis when they get exposed to it
they get tested for they do a blood test
to do a skin test to see if they have
tuberculosis is going to be a food
worker or something like that
they'll have antibodies but they'll have
a negative TB test when they're exposed
25 years ago you may have been exposed
when he's in Brazil or something like
that but life is it even mean you get a
fever the push in bed and you're near
death and all that kind of stuff
like you have a little pain in your
knees you got some radishes and things
like that okay okay what have Lyme
disease for 25 years even tuned
antibiotics every day for 25 years
didn't have Lyme disease they were
looting intolerance but doctors don't
think movement officer if they do they
don't want to be glued in town cuz
there's a code and insurance bug but for
Lyme disease only gonna do is write
Lyme's disease code number name doctor
and the insurance pays them okay and
once you understand that anything oh my
god so do this for 90 days and he'll be
a new man now let me give you a phone
number again and because I might be able
to do any more cuz we got to do an hour
half drive to get to our hotel here
we've got an early morning tomorrow I
need to leave in the next three minutes
and so there's two toll-free numbers I
want to give you one of them runs from
noon to 1:00 every day Monday through
Friday and do it for 23 years the second
one was in a different number will run
from 1 to 2 every day Monday through
Friday the first one that runs from noon
to 1 is triple 8 3 7 9 to 5 5 to as
Triple E at 8 8 8 3 7 9 to 5 5 to the
second one which runs from 1 to 2 in the
afternoon every day Monday through
Friday
there's also 12 three eight seven seven
nine one two seventy five to nine eight
seven seven nine one two seven five to
nine now let me say one more thing and
I'm going to turn this back over to Pete
and his crew they've done a great job
let's give them a hand
[Applause]
mission feeding it in here you see we
gave you a billion dollars worth of free
advice and we'll continue to give you
free advice we will charge you anything
for the information and it's very least
become what we call a preferred
customers Oh sales you never have to pay
retail prices and if you get three other
people going on the basic program the
healthy start tag every month
yours will be free every month that cool
now also there's different level to come
in as an associate or distributor they
tell you about this stuff and pay a
little bit of money ranging from $25
dollar to five hundred dollars you're
going to do any of those things right
now you can become free or preferred
customer you can start anywhere you want
in doing it you know the higher priced
ones later on get the stock options and
car bonuses and so when you when you pay
500 dollars you get more than five or
not for the product of your choice
okay so it's not like you're giving me
500 bucks one time maybe 500 bucks one
time if you're any all these bonuses and
all that stuff and we're told more than
$500 a pop this morning so you can look
around three two one now we're looking
for help and I realize it probably 85 or
some of the people who work with me our
customers my attention and my patients
which includes they really aren't
interested in you helping anybody else
are really not interesting in pages
be well and feel good and have a good
life which is okay that's nice
it makes me happy that that happens I
need help I'm willing to pay I've seen
about somebody get away a lot of free
product make it happen and so you're
prepared to spend a couple hours a week
at free training to be involved help
other people and you get an income
stream plus tax members remember you
don't get any tax benefits whatsoever as
an employee but when you have your own
little business starting even at the
bottom level at twenty five bucks one
time you get more than about 50 bucks
for the stuff show you how to run your
business all kinds of things you you
will get the same tax breaks that Warren
Buffett and Bill Gates and Don Sutton
all billionaires get now if you're
working in addition to doing the
youngevity thing you get withholdings
don't you the government they're your
boss holds money to give the government
the end of the year called withholding
tax now yeah
tax breaks now let's see here how far
did you come from Andrea
which is how Harper Drive okay so total
pie our 28 hours here to have hours
there okay and so you're looking at what
maybe 250 miles maybe each way 52 cents
a mile if deduct that you get any deduct
your space your home for your home
office
okay there's let's say you're you know
you're 25 make money if you only have
one job in a lady off
[Applause]
you